this weekend's gonna be kind of
interesting because we have the hippy
movie and we have the military movie and
those two are not exactly peanut butter
and jelly they're just not act of Valor
so active valor is a military Navy SEAL
movie that from the trailer
automatically tells you that the main
characters in this movie are actually
active duty Navy SEALs there is a
subtext to that and that is no one in
this movie is gonna put Salieri from
Amadeus to shame in terms of acting
which is not going to so I don't think
you can go into active valor and pick
apart the acting because right away they
tell you dude they're active duty Navy
SEALs what do you expect the what do you
expect that's subtext but it's there the
acting is not that great ladies and
gentlemen but that's not why I went to
the movie this is what I gathered from
the trailer that Act of Valor is gonna
be a very realistic and badass action
movie that pays respect to what active
duty military personnel and veterans do
and have gone through yet it's probably
a bit of a commercial for the Navy SEALs
and it was all those things what I liked
about this movies the action in this
movie spot-on like when they're going
through their missions they're talking
on the radio's you know it's all really
covert and quiet it was like Tom
Clancy's Rainbow six or something
the snipers picking dudes off and when
it all just the [ __ ] hits the fan you
like yeah so many of those moments in
this movie that it harkens back to the
80s action movies you know before CGI
took up every frame everything was all
gritty and real now once again it's all
gritty and real and that's great the
stuff that actually pissed me off wasn't
the acting it was the first-person
shooter mode I'm gonna call it that
which is a videogame term but did seem
like a video game it goes to the helmet
cam sometimes you see the gun out front
it looks just like what you're gonna
think of which is first-person shooter
game beginning but not ending with call
of duty it just felt like there were
sales pitching teenagers you know like
those commercials where it shows two
kids playing a first-person shooter game
the guy turns to the screen it's like
hey you want to do this for real and it
shows you know an actual military
battlegrounds what it felt like probably
what it was - I'll say this about active
Valor also right in the opening scene it
puts everything in perspective for you
right away you're like dude bad guys
need to die because that was some messed
up [ __ ] and yeah this movie does have
emotional tones to it and I like that
too I mean when you see these soldiers
hitting their lowest low at some points
you realize you're like these guys have
actually gone through this emotional
shitstorm and it actually kind of hits
you so was the acting great know what's
the plot of this movie original not
exactly was it a badass action movie you
bet and
pay respect to the men and women who
actually serve in the military and have
served in the military absolutely and I
think that's really important why
because everyone has an opinion about
the military everyone thinks they know
stuff but when you watch this movie you
realize you're like I actually haven't
seen the [ __ ] they've seen what why no
thank you to the men and women who serve
in the military and fight for our
freedom and give me the freedom to do
what I do I appreciate it
you all kick ass as an avid 80s action
movie fan I will say I would buy active
valor on blu-ray and I shall do just
that all the superb action of an 80s
action movie and all the acting that
goes with it cuz come on dude the 80s
action stars they weren't that great
they weren't really Van Damme Seagal no
so I imagine active aloes gonna divide
reviewers down the line if you're
looking for a cool action movie that
pays respect to active duty personnel
and does not have great acting which is
pretty much what the trailer tells you
it's gonna be you're gonna like the
movie if you're looking for a movie with
an original plot that's going for best
actor of 2012 not going to find it here
if you thought Hurt Locker was overrated
and boring check out Act of Valor there
it is so your favorite military movie or
a military action movie whatever it may
be comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]